[Music]
this morning on our saturday session
noel gallagher's high-flying birds
gallagher
is best known as co-founder of oasis one
of the best selling rock bands of all
time
a decade ago he launched a solo career
and
this month he celebrates the release of
a double album
of greatest hits he'll perform for us in
just a moment but our
anthony mason spoke with gallagher about
his career
and how he's been spending the long
months of this pandemic
in the middle of the pandemic noel
gallagher finished building a new studio
it's been his refuge
creatively it's been the best ever
because i've written
lots and lots of songs and songs that
were half finished it's like right well
i'll do that today because
i don't have anything else to do
his new album back the way we came
volume one
is a best of the first decade of noel
gallagher's high-flying birds
the band he formed after he split with
oasis
what do you see when you look back over
those 10 years well like you know i came
out of a
band with a very strong identity very
famous band
a band that fans really really loved
and i didn't want my solo career to be
a sugar-free version of that you know
like it like like diet oasis you know
what i mean
and um which is a great idea for a drink
somebody somebody should
write that down
[Music]
with the high-flying birds gallagher's
music broke free from the oasis sound
has it been liberating somehow in the
sense that i'm allowed to work at my own
pace
and i'm not writing songs for a brand
you know we were a stadium rock band
therefore i was writing stadium rock
songs i was writing for another singer
that singer was his brother liam you
said recently that wonderwall
is actually one of your least favorite
oasis songs one of my least favorite
recordings
uh-huh the song is great i mean the song
the song isn't actually still haven't
finished it
i'd have longed for a pandemic back then
i would have finished it properly it's
got one verse and one chorus and that's
really it
it's ironic that the biggest album we
ever made is a load of half finished
songs
the 1995 album what's the story morning
glory
sold more than 22 million copies
worldwide
[Music]
you may know about this me and me and my
brother fell out halfway through the
recording of the album
yes i've heard and never quite got to
finish them
and just said this will have to do
[Music]
another track off that album don't look
back in anger
is one of gallagher's favorites
[Music]
what it's become is something that i
could never
ever ever have imagined what is it
you're especially proud of
in the writing of it i don't know i
touched on something i don't know what
it is
in 2017 a terrorist bombing in
gallagher's hometown
manchester england killed 22 people
during the memorial a woman in the crowd
began
singing the song
that's when it kind of hits you it's
like well this song people have taken it
into their lives in it and
and it served a purpose that day it's
something i'd try not to think about
because it'll drive me mad of why
what is it about that song and i just
put it down to my something was in the
air that night i wrote it in paris and
fell out of the sky and thankfully it
landed on my lap and not bono's